first of all I love the new fragrance
it's gorgeous out of all of you he was
most hands-on with a scent I'd say me
definitely I was definitely the most
hands-on with this would you say now
it's a we were honor but we didn't do
have so much to do no no no I did all
the ground where fish fragrance and I'm
gonna take full credit
well then you'd like it it's kind of a
sexy one this one it may be a bit more
growing up than the previous two
sexually so it's really okay did you
have a particular kind of girl in mind
when creating the sense I think it was
more yeah when you asked me the other
day who would be the type of girl who'd
wear our fragrance I did say a sexy girl
you did you did up say yes yes so there
you go so it does exactly what my job is
I go between your world tour and your
new movie and this rate education you've
all gotten lots on your plate what is
your secret to not driving yourself
crazy and just don't take yourself too
seriously I think otherwise you'll get
swallowed up in this game I say yes game
I've seen so many go this industry huh
yourself you know and with it's a hectic
schedule are any of you guys into things
like juicing with detoxing super healthy
living and are you well forwarding on
kale back baby that's what we mean about
taking yourself too seriously yeah yeah
you know skin with some junk food yeah
where we go
yacon okay that those kind of juices
actually do offend me yeah yeah I'll
just fill out it with me off the nerves
got this juice yeah there for me come on
okay so yeah okay and do you feel
pressure to look good and more
importantly smell good at all times I
like the smell good
you've always got a smell well as long
as you don't smell bad yeah I mean it's
a medium and you sound like you're what
if you get in the middle ground
yeah like clean but not like a good
aftershave you're doing alright good so
please can we talk about tattoos have
you ever thought about getting a
matching 1d path you leave us one that
way yeah find it you're like where is it
good
and then these on the ankles is all the
litter boxes on the I'm just
Oh Niles bit nervy huh
well Florida do i don't yeah yeah it's
okay you look you're the collector
yeah I'm really cool inside this magnet
right he's kooky I am the trendsetter
sizes make this really kicker kooky and
quirky okay so you have the fragrance
and the yet to be revealed beauty lines
it's just the beginning of more exciting
1d projects and can we expect clothes
home where bars
errata expect the unexpected
now we're going to say that it's a good
answer big things are coming into
pipeline big things music I think big
I'm with the X Factor back on our twins
will you be popping by see AB Mel B and
Cheryl a bottle of the new perfume
definitely we should definitely do that
sweet side
yeah just kick it unlike the well panel
with them just keep the cursor next to
that glass the wall
yeah yeah yeah definitely I just look
better on duce and Sheamus Bluegreen
yeah exactly yeah it's hideous really
okay I'm living with the ring I am
loving it here look what anima tell you
have a say in the designing of this ring
yeah yeah every part of it you can you
can the top spot to a chain you're
wearing on your finger see we were all
over when we're yeah chain rings
probably the best option isn't it cuz it
rings quick peek neither brings nice
happiness yeah that's not fair is it Sam
and lastly so um you've obviously got
those of guy fans have you ever thought
about doing a men's flavor would you
spoke about this last one maybe unisex
do they do fragrances that you said nice
people
yeah yeah I think I think that might be
more appropriate yeah thanks right down
the middle
men's after ship might not work I'm not
sure my no unisex sounds good thank you
lastly why should the glamour girl buy
the new frame
it's glamorous yet I suppose if you like
smell good then you should just buy the
1d fragrances any well cuz I think it's
good huh I really like our hard work
it's inside us because now thinks it's
good yeah exactly and what now says goes
exactly
least until at least I know is on yes
Jacek you say thank you so much for
talking to me
thank you